-Our first guest is
one of the co-hosts
of "Good Morning America".
He also has a new clothing line
called MSX by Michael Strahan.
Here he is, the one
and only Michael Strahan.
♪ Michael Strahan ♪
♪ He's one of a kind ♪
♪ Sharp as a razor,
he's got his own clothing line ♪
♪ Michael Strahan
gonna make you laugh ♪
♪ When we talk to him
about the NFL draft ♪
-Unbelievable.
-It is great. It is great
to see you.
-Always, always,
you are the best.
Thank you. You just crushed me
yet again at golf.
-We had fun.
-[ Laughs ]
-We had a lot of fun.
I really thought
I was going to lose.
-I was right.
-Because you're good.
-No, I was not good at all.
That was terrible.
That was awful.
I didn't get one in at all.
It was terrible.
-We could we could edit it.
[ Laughter ]
-Buddy, I want to talk to you
about a bunch of things,
but first, the NFL draft
is coming up April 29th,
and what what goes through --
since you've done this --
what goes through your head
when you're knowing
that you're going to get
drafted to a team.
-I hope.
Like, you hope
you get drafted.
-Like, unless you're
Trevor Lawrence,
you don't really know
where you're going to go.
You know you're going to go
to Jacksonville,
but other than that,
you just hope you're going
to get drafted.
You're praying you
can, like, make enough money
so you don't have to live
with your parents anymore.
And -- but then,
when you get drafted,
it doesn't mean
that you've made it,
and I think that's what a lot
of young players get mixed up.
They think, "I got drafted,
I made it"
-Right.
-They go get the car,
the jewelry and everything else
that comes with it.
No, that's just your opportunity
to be in the NFL.
You know, you haven't made it.
That's when your work
really starts,
because if you don't
put it in the work,
you won't be there long.
And, you know,
with football careers,
even when they are long like
mine -- I retired at 36.
Yeah. You got a long life
to live afterwards, hopefully,
so got to take care
of your money.
Save your money, kids.
Save your money.
-[ Laughs ] Exactly, yeah.
-And put in all the work,
and you get out of it
what you put into it.
-Yeah.
-Plain and simple.
-What do you remember
about the first day
going into the locker room
for the Giants,
or coming to New York --
what do you remember?
-I was scared as hell.
I was scared.
-Really?
-I'm in this locker room.
I'm not, like, a big guy,
but I'm watching
these grown men.
-Yes, you are.
-I'm not a big guy.
Have you seen
some of these guys?
6'7", 6'8", Solid muscle.
330, 40, 50 pounds.
And then the guys who played
my position, one of these guys,
he was so -- he had muscles
coming out of everywhere, neck,
ears, everything.
-Ear muscles?
-Yeah, ear muscles.
And he walks in the --
he walks in the locker room.
It's the first time I'd ever
been there with the vets,
and he was a vet. He walks in
and I just remember
looking at him thinking,
"He plays my position.
If I have to look
like him to play,
I might as well go home. I'm
never going to look like that.
-Really?
-Ah, it was intimidating.
So I remember being scared.
I remember Lawrence Taylor
walking into the locker room...
-Yeah! LT, man.
-...And it was like he didn't
even walk, he glided in
like he was
on a conveyor belt.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, he floated in.
-He was so like...
He was such a god to me
in football.
So, yeah, it was --
it was intimidating,
but the sooner you can get over
and realize you're there
because you deserve to be there
and that you belong,
then the better
it'll be for you.
But it's intimidating at first.
-And did you feel comfortable
in New York City?
-No.
No. The first time I came here,
I stayed in
the Marriott Marquis,
right in Times Square.
-Yeah.
-I didn't leave my room
until somebody came and got me.
Because I'm not that big, Jimmy.
-Yes, you are!
You are that big!
-I'm going to be
in New York City
and I'm going to be walking
looking at, like, don't look up.
I'm walking,
looking at buildings like that,
because I don't want to look up.
I don't want to look like
a tourist!
That's all the things I heard
when I came in from Texas.
Like, "Don't look up.
They're going to rob you.
They're going to mug you."
-[ Laughs ]
-I know, yeah.
-So, I'm like waiting
in the hotel. You come get me,
then I'll leave
because I got somebody with me
to help me if I needed help.
And it was intimidating.
I hear somebody's laughing.
-Yeah, that's --
-I'm being honest. I was scared
to -- It was scary.
-But I think you're good
at doing things
that are a little challenging.
I think that you like
a good challenge.
-Yes.
-Even like going into
"Good Morning America".
Like, you don't know
how to host a morning show,
but yet you hit it
out of the park.
You're fantastic at it.
-Thank you. Thank you.
You know what?
That was -- that was more
intimidating
than being in a locker room
with the big old dudes
walking in there, man.
-Really?
-Yeah, I was --
That is the hardest,
most challenging job
I've ever had.
-Really?
-Football is challenging
mentally and physically,
but this -- just
the overall pressure of it,
you feel it a lot more than
I ever felt on a football field.
And so it's really hard
to explain,
but it challenged me in
different ways I never expected,
because it's not something
that I can say I aspired to do.
-Yeah.
-But now, I absolutely love it.
I'm so comfortable there.
I love the news.
I love politics.
I love, you know, everything
that's involved with it.
I just wish the news could be
a little bit happier at times.
-Yeah
-It's kind of hard.
It's like 7 AM going,
"Well, you know, today..."
It's like -- it wears on
your mind some of these things,
but, I -- I wouldn't
change it for the world.
My career and where it's taken
has exceeded anything
I ever imagined, so.
-I mean your clothing line
has taken off as well.
Last time we were on, we talked
about -- you were giving suits,
by the way, to veterans
and helping them get jobs
when they come out of
the service,
and I thought that was
an awesome thing you did.
-Thank you.
-And...
But this is your --
Is it --
What do you call, is it...?
-"Work leisure," we call it.
-Work leisure.
-You know, there's athleisure,
and then theres tailored,
which is like suits and ties,
but now everybody's
like leisure,
but they're working, because
they're working from home.
-That's right.
-So what we have,
we have fitted Polo's, we have,
you know, comfortable joggers,
and also we have jeans
and everything else.
Throw a jacket over it,
you can sit in front of
your Zoom,
you can do your thing.
Take it off,
you could still hit the streets,
and not have to change
20 outfits to kind of work now
and also be at home
and be comfortable.
-Look at your model poses.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Now, are any of these,
like, real situations?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
All that's in the studio.
It is weird,
because it's like -- I felt
like "Talladega Nights".
What do I do with my hands?
You know, you just kind of --
So, you notice,
I almost have something
in my hands every time.
-Yeah.
-And then when you do the suit,
it's, weird because I saw that
that meme of The Rock
and he's always fixing
his cuffs.
-Yeah.
-Like, can The Rock ever fix
his cuffs?
-[ Laughs ]
-So now every time
I've got a suit,
I'm like, "I can't do
the cuff thing --
that's The Rock's stuff.
That's The Rock's thing.
But, yeah, it's uncomfortable --
there's, like, a lot of people
standing around you, like, kind
of like "What do I do?"
-I know.
-I got to look cool.
-But I think you always had
a little something,
because we got a photo
of young Michael Strahan.
-Oh boy.
-Look at this little stud.
That's what I'm talking about
right there.
That's my man right there.
Walk me --
walk me through this, dude.
-How cool is he?
-I'm -- I'm the youngest of 6,
and I was too young
to go to school,
but my brothers and sisters
had school pictures,
and I cried and told my mom
"I want to go to school,
and I want school pictures."
So she took me to Sears
or something,
where they used to do the school
pictures --
-Yes, of course.
-Where you can get the pictures.
And that was considered
my school picture,
even though I wasn't in school,
and you could tell I was happy.
-That's a good mom.
-Because the gap is just
in awful display.
-You're going to have to
add this to the MSX line.
Leisure suits.
-The lei--
That's polyester. Don't get near
a flame, you going up.
-This is my man,
Michael Strahan.
Everybody give it up --
in studio.
Check out his line of
MSX clothing available now.